oh my god everybody that was amazing
this is going to be my arrow 100th
episode video it's part three of the
crossover and the flash ring giveaway is
still going on what a crazy 100th
episode I thought they did a good job of
including everyone even people that
couldn't make it because of scheduling
problems so just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet and
there is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway going on all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video be sure to turn
alerts on I will be announcing a winner
at the end of this but let's talk about
all this matrix craziness so top 10 WTF
comic book Easter eggs most of the
Easter eggs they included were for
things that they've done on arrow they
were internal Easter eggs so they opened
the episode number 10 with Oliver
running through a bunch of trees this is
like a long held arrow tradition with
Oliver opening each season like the
episode one with him running through
trees into some other situation but
surprise he's in the backyard of the
queen mansion which got blown up between
seasons a couple years ago so they
opened the episode completely in
dreamland which is in stark contrast to
the way they ended the last episode with
them all getting beamed up after that
crazy epic battle so Stephen Amell
actually said look very specifically
like he is an actor doesn't get to give
notes lot but they do ask him for input
when they give him scripts and like hey
you know what do you think of this
episode that we're getting ready to
shoot and every once in a while he'll
get to like throw something in he said
that like his big thing with the
hundredth episode was that because they
were going to be doing such crazy stuff
is that he wanted to open the episode
with music in like a different way like
to do it completely differently to let
you know that this wasn't a normal
episode so I'll talk about this as I
work through Easter eggs but like they
had music cues like a League of
Assassins music cue for Sarah when she
said something about not being an
assassin so there were like little bits
that they added just to let you know
that this is completely different but
because of all the hype going into it
all the info they've been dropping I
think most of us understood that this
was going to be like a special matrix
Dream Land situation but number 9
speaking of which we meet Laurel Lance
she is engaged to Oliver like in the
comics and a lot of people were probably
have
about that but as he starts saying hello
to everyone he sees his father his
mother then Thea gives him the hosen
that he gave to her after coming back
from the island in the pilot episode so
there were like a lot of things
happening in this episode that went all
the way back to the pilot
especially Oliver's father because he
died in the pilot but number 8 back in
the real world Sisko comes in and has to
vibe Oliver's bow to find out that
they're all on that ship and they
reverse-engineer the dominator
technology with a whole bunch of movie
references oh this is my c-3po chip oh
you make movie references that's so lame
like Sisko is mr. movie reference so the
story line that was happening outside of
the episode was relatively brief like
most of the episode was dedicated to
this arrow storyline because it's the
hundredth episode so you don't like
hijack it with a bunch of other stuff
but number 8 like the big doctor who
referenced the Cybermen referenced a
woman basically grafting technology on
to herself they have to get a piece from
it in order to help the people that are
trapped on the spaceship so Barry and
Cara team up with the rest of team arrow
with a whole bunch of jokes about Barry
caring people like pretty much every
funny moment that they've had where
flash crosses over with arrow characters
like Diggle freaking out and throwing up
every time Barry carries him they tried
to touch on that but they also had this
arc with wild dog kind of coming around
on metahumans like I don't trust you you
make things worse but by the end of the
episode they were completely cool so you
know number seven Barry and Cara versus
the cyber woman just total tag team it
was awesome just like the brief amount
of those characters that you needed just
to remember that there's like larger
stuff going on besides the arrow matrix
hundredth episode stuff so number six we
meet Sara in the Dream Land she touches
laurels canary necklace oh what a
coincidence she starts to remember
things
Oliver starts to have flashes he catches
the vase he notices the smoke
technologies building they have that
very Batman moment where they almost get
mugged in the alley but they're saved by
mystery Green Arrow Oh wonder who that
was but Oliver's father gives him this
big speech about doing the responsible
thing hey takeover is Queen consolidated
CEO let's keep it in the family I'm
getting ready to run for mayor
so they're touching on storylines from
back in season one his father starts
talking about the work that he's doing
isn't finished yet which was one of the
final lines that he told to Oliver
before he died
Oliver's just been sworn in as mayor so
basically like all the conversations
they're having in all the Easter eggs
are all blends of everything that's ever
happened on arrow they're all like
mixing and matching things but the more
Oliver starts talking to people the more
he touches things sees really like
significant things from his past he
starts to freak out have hallucinations
of what really happened sees visions of
Laurel his father his mother dying in
that number five when he goes to see
Quentin who has a really funny speech
does not seem like a broken-down
alcoholic says Oliver's like a really
great person despite him not being super
hot on him before so he goes to where
the current arrow cave is sees it as it
is currently in present-day with the
addition of a giant fern in frame right
next to felicity and in swings the Green
Arrow intruder alert it's Diggle the
last time I think we saw Diggle in the
green arrow costume was during season 3
before Oliver got like his big suit
upgrade so diggle's in full crazy mode
he hasn't like woken up to the fact that
he's in a matrix he's speaking to Oliver
in a version of Stephen amell's arrow
voice which itself is kind of a version
of Batman voice so Diggle Batman voice
was kind of funny but the five people
that are in the matrix just remember is
Oliver Diggle Sara Thea and Ray Palmer
so eventually they all start to come
together like once they start touching
each other they start to remember they
figure it out
number four they're gonna try and keep
us trapped in here like Diggle pulls out
the picture of the Dominator in surprise
surprise Deathstroke appears just whips
his sword out it was one of the greatest
introductions ever so I don't think that
Manu Bennett was underneath that mask
otherwise he would have torn it off they
would have had him on screen but just
like Tommy I think that Manu Bennett was
unavailable because he himself is a
series regular on a couple of other
shows so it was just like no way they
could make it work so they found a way
to make Deathstroke work but Sara comes
in and saves them because like Oliver
hasn't quite fully remembered that he's
a really badass fighter like it takes on
most of the episode to figure everything
out like okay we have to get out of here
but number three the wedding reception
so this is funny we had the Thea Merlyn
moment where they totally name-dropped
Tommy who is a mysterious doctor in
Chicago could not make it the funny
thing about this like if you don't know
Colin Donald the actor who played Tommy
is a series regular on Chicago med he
plays a doctor on that show so this was
the writers saying that Tommy couldn't
come to Oliver in laurels wedding
reception because he's a doctor on
another show like you know just laughing
about that but then Laurel makes a joke
about Sarah hooking up with Oliver oh
you know I'm a lesbian but you know that
Sarah in season 1 was on the Queen's
Gambit hooking up with Oliver so -
Oliver says it's really tearful goodbye
to his mother or father and then the
teen tries to leave and has to fight off
the combined forces of Deathstroke
Malcolm Merlyn is the dark Archer damian
darhk-- in one of the mirakuru soldiers
so Oliver puts another arrow through
Deathstroke sigh just a little easter
egg from season 1 and from season 2 when
he did it to Slade Wilson and I was
really happy that they gave Oliver that
final goodbye moment where he's seeing
the visions of all the people that are
most important to him just kind of
reassuring him that the decisions he's
made were the right ones he's a good
person just give him like the bump that
he needs and they find a way to include
footage of Tommy and Roy who could not
make it for the episode I was kind of
bummed that they weren't around but the
producers explained there was just like
no way they could make it work with
those actors schedules so bit of a
bummer maybe sometime in the back half
colton can come back I definitely think
that Tommy and Roy will come back for an
episode in the future it just depends on
when they're available and whatever
story it is they want to bring him back
for but all that talk does throw a lot
of water on the idea that Tommy might be
prometheus
so if Colin Donal was so busy that he
could not make it for the arrow 100th
episode then I think it'd be really hard
for him to be a big villain in the back
half of the season as prometheus but
number one they escaped and the team
learns that the dominators language is
based on Hebrew or at least it shares a
lot in common with Hebrew just because
the
is trying to tease that there is like a
larger galactic community and they share
a lot in common like humans are not this
singular thing they're part of this
giant organism that is the universe with
many races that we will hopefully
eventually meet now that kind of gets
into Green Lantern really big space
based stuff but this idea that they
share a lot in common with the aliens
will come back later
this is them just laying seeds they're
kind of doing more of this stuff on
Supergirl but mr. terrific has that line
about not wanting to turn it into a
religious thing there is a God in the DC
universe that takes a couple of
different forms he's known as the
presence he gets used a lot in Lucifer
Neil Gaiman stories he doesn't appear a
whole lot in the main DC Comics just
because it's really hard to tell a story
when a character is completely
invincible like Superman seems
invincible but he does have weaknesses
so it just makes it almost impossible to
write a story with conflict about a
character that can't be beaten so that's
why you don't see God a whole lot in the
DC Universe but he's also known as the
source the place where the new gods get
their powers from so when they talk
about divine plan they're just kind of
hinting at new gods stuff like that like
bigger larger Green Lantern galactic
stuff happening but I will say this is
my favorite arrow episode in as long as
I can remember I felt like they did a
really good job of hitting beats with
each of the characters they gave Thea
that really nice moment with Moira
Oliver got really nice moments with his
parents they all got really nice moments
with Laurel so I like the way they wrote
the characters the interactions the
sentiment so now my head is spinning a
little bit as to how they're going to
bring Laurel back in the back half of
the season because that's still like a
completely separate thing well let's
talk about that after the mid-season
finale because I don't think we're going
to learn about that till Talia al Ghul
and Laurel come back in episode 10
supposedly they'll be Laurel stuff in
episode 10 but there is definitely Talia
stuff happening but I think that's
mostly for the flashbacks so just a
heads up the next part of the crossover
is legends of tomorrow like they get
saved by the Waverider so obviously
they'll pick up with that in tomorrow's
episode so hopefully if I can get it out
in time I'll do an arrow finale trailer
video like an arrow episode 9 trailer
video for the Prometheus
stuff then I'll do Rick and Morty which
I meant to do today and then I'll do my
legends video but I'll say
congratulations to the current giveaway
winner Nightwolf you win the first flash
ring so I'll announce the next winner
when I post my legends video tomorrow so
I'll just remind people about the
giveaway when I post the DC videos so no
worries if you guys are behind on the
crossover I will add links for the other
crossover videos that I've done at the
end of this well you guys wait for that
to post you can click here for next
week's flash trailer it's totally crazy
and you can click here for part two of
the crossover thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight